mardi matin 9 heures julien débute sa
journée de livraison direction la
verrière chez patrick bellot ce client a
acheté trois stères de bois de chauffage
soit environ 3 mètres cubes de bûches
pour guignery les notes de de chauffage
moi moche enfants tout électrique donc
ça permet de diminuer la facture edf
comme lui de nombreux français se
chauffent au bois 51 millions de stères
sont consommées chaque année une demande
toujours importante qui a poussé
l'office national des forêts et la
société molinario à ouvrir un nouveau
point de vente
inaugurée le 16 octobre julien en est le
responsable
donc nous on est sur du bois sec qui
peut être rude à broder immédiatement
par les clients d'équilibré qu'il rentre
ça permet de d'avoir une meilleure
combustion du bois qui libère l'énergie
de chauffage ce qui permet aussi de
parrot crasse et votre cheminée le
carburant ou le ou plutôt la l'énergie
de demain et ça fait partie des énergies
renouvelables et donc il est important
aussi que l'eau neuf montre cet exemple
là en disant que le bois est important
dans l'avenir pour consommer être
consommés en tant que bois énergie
désormais le n9 molinario dispose de
trois sites de distribution de bois de
chauffage ce dernier situé à
vieille-église en yvelines pourra
alimenter plus facilement le secteur de
rambouillet il est possible de se faire
livrer ou de retirer sa commande
directement sur place